what is acting thanks for that question
because a lot of people think that
acting is lying
and that's you know one of those things
that I think is the most important thing
about it is that it's my my teacher my
my teacher my
special teacher Gene Shelton who just
passed away recently
um used to say that uh people think that
acting is lying but really acting is
being more truthful than you get to be
in real life
and that was always the that was always
the joy of it for me I always felt like
a little bit of a fraud in real life and
I always felt like characters were
saying and doing things that I was
didn't dare to do that they were that
they were a deeper part of me
so
that's what I love about acting is that
it's more truthful than real life it's
not lying at all
um and and a very common definition is
acting as living truthfully under
imaginary circumstances
that's a definition that a lot of people
use I did want to mention that
um
when I was learning acting when I was in
acting class back in the 1970s
are
God if you will was Marlon Brando
and um
and in those days you know you didn't
have access to all kinds of ways of
finding out about uh actors they didn't
talk about things and they weren't
interviewed but and Brando was of course
notoriously uh reserved and um but he
was going to be on a Dick Cavett you
know a big interview show so everybody
in our class we all
stayed home
no be you know no way to record things
in those days we all stayed home to
watch Brando on be interviewed on the
Dick Cavett Show and
um
he said he said well acting everybody is
nothing it's uh it's just everybody acts
all the time because people never tell
you what they really think so everybody
is acting all the time and we're so
disappointed to hear him say that
because we've we felt so you know
involved in our craft and so uh deeply
deeply connected to the truthfulness and
the of of acting and and finding the
truth of the character the truth of the
play or film and um
but what I come to think is that what he
was saying what he really meant is that
whatever people say there is subtext to
it
okay and that I do think is exactly
right that in real life as well as for
characters in a movie or television show
or play there's always subtext to what
people are saying so in real life people
will ask you how you are and you will
say I'm fine and that will be very often
a lie right but there's if you let
yourself believe that there's always
subject so for example if you ask me how
are you and I might say well I'm shitty
but uh this is my subtex threat this is
what I'm not saying I feel really shitty
but I'm going to give you a break and
not tell you all about it instead I'm
going to say I'm fine
okay so even when that seems like a lie
somebody says how are you and I say I'm
fine it seems like a lie but really
there's always subtext and
um and that's true for acting there's
always subtext so in that sense I've
come around to understanding that that
that Brando's uh definition of acting is
also completely valid
why do you say that acting is more
honest than real life because real life
is so Bound by the social parameters by
what's socially acceptable
and characters go way outside of what's
socially acceptable they go into places
of deep pain they go into places of
transgression they go into places of uh
of joy and and uh
exuberance that isn't really socially
acceptable
um
and and in fact
let me put this another way
a lot of feeling is not socially
acceptable
when people
in in real life we don't want anybody to
know how we feel most of the time
if somebody makes us angry
we don't want to show it
and we even say to each other don't let
that person get to you
don't let him know that he bothers you
right and that's a real watch for it for
getting along in the social world is to
not let people know when they when
they've upset you to not let them know
if they've hurt your feelings to not let
them know if they've made you angry to
not and very often
to not let them know if uh if they've
turned you on if they've you know made
you feel excited in their presence
so
and actors get to do that they they get
to they get to express things that are
very human things that
um
that in real life are are frowned upon
you know the social parameters are very
strict
often
so the notion that acting is lying where
do you think that came from
from people who don't know anything
about acting well I think if you don't
know anything about how
what acting is about is really about the
subtext
then it's easy to think that it's it
it's not that people are stupid for
thinking that because an actor is
pretending to be in love with somebody
when they're married to somebody else or
they're you know they're they're
pretending to uh murder somebody
uh when they're when they claim that
they're an upstanding citizen so
um
I could see where where it comes from
that it you know that it has to do with
uh that people would think that
but it's unfortunate
um it it has to do with not
understanding this idea of subtext that
that an actor can be completely truthful
with their own subtext and an actor
never needs to let go of their own
values or their own uh yeah their own
values their own ethics
an actor never needs to let go of those
and and I don't know I like to keep
telling people about that that that uh
you know an actor can be capable of
approaching every character without
judgment very important for an actor not
to judge their character to to be on
their character's side to look for the
ways that the character is
doing what they think is best is doing
the best they can
but without and to understand that as a
craft
and it doesn't mean that you have to let
go of your own ethics sure but you could
say that we all have certain parts of
every character in us whether we act
exactly exactly we all have impulses we
all have we all have every impulse every
single person has every single impulse
in them somewhere now for some people
they're buried so far down that they
won't wouldn't recognize it in
themselves for actors they allow those
things to be buried less far down you
know so that they can access them but it
doesn't mean that they change their
beliefs about what's right and wrong
why is acting an exercise in empathy it
has a lot to do with the Judgment issue
with feeling that there's that every
character is doing what they think is
right what they think is best they have
a reason everybody has a reason for
everything that they do I once read a
short story
um and unfortunately I don't remember
the author but it was a wonderful short
story and it had this line there's a
reason for everything and sometimes too
and I've just always clasped that to my
heart as something very essential about
acting about script analysis about
directors understanding actors and
understanding characters everybody has a
reason for what they're doing it might
be a reason that the rest of us would
look at from the outside and say that's
a crappy reason that's a stupid reason
that's a wrong reason of course we we
all have the the audience has the right
to judge
but but the actor has to come from a
place of you know what the that they
that the character is operating out of a
need they they need something and
they're they're doing what they can to
get there so so it's deeply empath
empathetic
um and I and I actually believe that
that acting is
a kind of spiritual practice I'm one of
those I'm one of those people that that
feels that way about it uh for myself
when I got into acting I I had no I I
had no notion of making a career at it I
had no notion I certainly had no notion
of being a movie star or
or anything like that I I was was the
1970s and I was looking for
um something to do that would be
fulfilling that would make me understand
the world better and understand myself
better
acting was perfect uh partly because of
my wonderful teacher who just seemed to
know so much about life and about why
people do things why why characters do
the things they do
and also why people do the things they
do
so it was always very personal for me I
I always it was always a learning uh
a learning experience learning about
myself learning about the world learning
why people do the things they do
and um
and and so that's certainly an exercise
in empathy
I think I I I always try to ask
directors to expect that that's What
actors are there for that they're
students of life that they want to uh
know more about about people and about
the world and that if directors approach
them that way as artists and as ethical
people
that they will be able to communicate
better and be able to communicate their
Vision better
would you see actors that had different
levels of empathy maybe empathy toward
their scene partner but less so with
themselves and that became a problem in
their performances
can you give me an example well you know
how some people are incredibly harsh on
themselves whether it's you know
something that's been said to them in
the past that they carry with them so
then they they always carry that
everywhere they go and maybe they would
take that in a scene and they might
treat their scene partner well but then
for themselves the empathy wasn't there
actors are not actors are notoriously
hard on themselves
always 90
there's you know to the extent that when
you hear a story of an actor who's not
hard on themselves I'm going to give you
one in a second it's really exciting and
amazing and and blows uh other actors
Minds there's a story about Meryl Streep
that I read in an article it was an
interview with Chris Cooper who played
opposite her in adaptation and he said
that every every time
that a take got blown or or didn't work
or she made a mistake or or something
went wrong she would after that just go
huh
okay let's go it again and she never
lost her her
Joy of acting she never came down on
herself she never she never many actors
after that something happens I'll go oh
and she never did that and he was
shocked he'd never seen it so I would
say you know 90 or 99 maybe of actors
are very hard on themselves and then
those sparkling one percent or ten
percent are are uh are unusual but of
course they have so much freedom and of
course you want actors to have that kind
of freedom and I've taught actors for a
long time at acting classes and I always
wanted them to have that freedom to
forgive themselves to to uh and that
that's why I say to directors you know
permission to fail is the most valuable
thing that you can give an actor is you
you can tell them uh
don't worry we'll do it again if if I
won't use anything that doesn't work so
um we have all the time in the world and
even telling an actor we have all the
time in the world even if you don't
you'll actually get the shot faster than
if you uh say to an actor okay we've
only got one more we've only got time
for one more shot so we've got to get it
on this shot
it's actually less likely to go well
than if you say you know we've got all
the time in the world let's just do one
more
and uh you're more likely to get
something good out of out of that
permission to fail that it's okay if you
fail
would you see empathy
um the degrees of empathy maybe Blossom
more let's say there's a scale and when
a student would come to you in the past
for the the classes in you know the
workshops uh that their empathy they
were closed off and you could see it in
them whether it was family conditioning
and then over time the scale that they
came more to this side where
they just were open open to themselves
open to other people well that was
always my hope of course
it's always my hope
I I try not to make myself responsible
for whether that happens or not but but
it's always my hope that that people
well that
whether they're acting or whether
they're directing that uh or whether
they're writing that it will open them
up that it will that it will connect
them more to
to uh what they what they feel is
important about life and and I I used to
feel this way when I was an actor myself
when I was in plays I was in plays a lot
all during the 70s and uh and I used to
approach every role with the idea that
once the show closed I would know more
about myself than I did at the start of
rehearsal
and I think that I think that's that
helped because that's something that
really can happen if you say well I'm
going to take this take this role
because I can be really great in it and
I'm gonna do it better than anybody else
well that's something that you really
have no control over whether that's
going to happen or not but you have more
control over whether it's going to
happen that you're going to learn
something
so I always I always think of that as a
good it's a good place to come from for
anybody in the Arts that if your goal on
any project is to learn something then
you really can't go wrong you will
you'll you will reach your goal if your
goal is to learn something you will
reach that goal if your goal is to be
perfect to be to be great to blow
everybody out of the water well there's
I don't know there's a lot of room for
disappointment
what are the biggest misconceptions
people have about actors that they're
too sensitive that their antenna is
always up that they're constantly
watching themselves in the mirror walk
you know almost as a character walking
into a scene well I think for directors
the directors that I meet and I you know
I taught workshops for directors for
many years and now I do sometime I do
some Consulting with uh directors
getting preparing to make a project and
I think
I think the biggest
misconception is that that they're
fragile somehow
that uh that you can't dare talk to them
because they'll go into a so they'll
start crying or go into a rage or or or
or get upset if they're uh if you say
anything about about their about their
work and
I suppose where this comes from is that
actors do tend to be more expressive
than
actors sort of tend to call them
civilians people who are not actors tend
to be in the world of actors civilians
so actors are more expressive
um and they might they might cry if you
tell them that uh the last take they
were overacting a bit but they get over
it
they're more comfortable they're
comfortable with feelings and the way I
see it the misconception on the part of
people who are not actors that actors
are you know too too excitable to uh
to be agitated too quickly is
that
in in real life we're not allowed to do
that I think anybody would do that if
they could and
um
we're we're conditioned out of it
children
respond whatever they feel they express
right they feel they're hurt they cry
they're angry they scream and then
little by little we condition them so
they'll be in society we say use your
words
and we're we're when when we tell and
I'm not saying we shouldn't do this but
when we tell children use your words
instead of acting out your feelings
we're asking them to intellectualize
their feelings and that's the process of
society as intellectualizing our
feelings so that people can get along
and everybody can you know get to work
every day and and uh
you know not scream at each other when
um
on although of course that's happening
more than people screaming at each other
it's so strange but reverting to that uh
kind of childish behavior But but so
it's good if people don't revert to
their childish behavior in the form of
road rage but um but for actors it's
part of a craft
it's you know let being available to
their feelings being able to uh cry or
or stomp their feet is is part of their
craft and
um I think I think sometimes directors
take it personally they think oh they
hate me you know oh they're they're
they're fragile but actors aren't that
fragile they really like to be told
um we were talking earlier about you
know if you have lipstick on your teeth
or something they really want to know
that it shouldn't be awkward at all to
tell an actor that there's lipstick on
their teeth that uh because they don't
want to be photographed with lipstick on
their teeth so they're grateful if
someone tells them
and uh and and also if they're
overacting I mean it might it might be
it might be upsetting for them to hear
that but in the end they would rather
hear that than be cut out of the movie
which you might have to do in the
editing room if the if the performance
isn't good enough
and so let's suppose I love that analogy
of the lipstick on the teeth
um I'm doing a scene and you've noticed
that I have lipstick on my teeth you're
you're pulling me aside privately to
tell me this what's the best way to say
you know Karen could I talk to you for a
moment well actually the makeup person
should take care of this ah okay the
makeup person should take care of this
but uh uh should be watching for this
and and should be running up and uh and
taking care of it um
the
but it should be everything should be
private everything should be private if
the makeup person hasn't stepped forward
and you have to say to the makeup person
will you go and take care of there's
makeup on her teeth would you take care
of that then
um there's no need to announce it to the
crew
right and when I when directors have
something to give direction or to say
something about the take that just
happened or what they want to try in the
next one that should always be private
always be private the act the director
should come up and take the the uh actor
away a little bit uh and privately or
whisper Whispering is uh is useful it's
never helpful to give a direction that
the rest of the crew can hear
and the reason for that is that then the
crew is watching
to see if the actor takes that direction
and the actor knows that they're being
watched not just by the director who
hopefully they trust and want to please
but by a whole bunch of people who who
may not know so much about acting
they're watching being watched by a
whole bunch of people and maybe even
gossiped about
uh so
it's very uh very very helpful for an
actor's safety to to speak to uh for the
director to speak to the actors
privately always away from away from the
producers away from the
um crew
and and it's it's it says it creates a
safety for the director as well
because I like to encourage directors to
be vulnerable around actors
and to to be able to say to them look
you know something's off here and I
don't know what it is
can you talk can you do you have some
ideas about what we might do here
and you don't want to say that in front
of the crew you want that to be a
private conversation between you and the
actor
but I do think it's very very helpful
for directors to be able to tell an
actor when they're when they
when they're not sure what's wrong
just you know to instead of jumping into
Fix-It mode a lot of directors feel like
oh something's wrong I have to fix it
but I want to encourage a collaboration
between directors and actors where the
um you know where you draw you you you
pick their brains you you bring them
into the process you you use their ideas
and their skills
to help you solve problems that you
solve problems together if there are
problems
you'd said earlier about
um actors calling a quote-unquote
normies or whatever civilian civilians
right so not not normally so okay so
civilians it almost brings me back to
let's say in the workplace if you've
ever worked in an office like a
nine-to-five job and the quiet and just
you hear the typing and the picking up
hello and it just it's so subdued but
then if you've ever worked in a
restaurant or the service industry it's
wild and crazy and people are yelling
and that's acceptable in that world to a
degree as long as people are somewhat
professional but it almost sounds like
that's the the analogy of what we see as
as performers is sort of this bar
environment versus the subdued Library
office where no one raises their voice
everyone speaks in a very calm tone but
is that really true are actors really
that that they can go there too they can
be
you know some actors are all different
actors are all different and some actors
really like to be alone in between takes
and not be sociable and other actors
like to horse around and and uh
jabber with their with their fellow
actors
um they're all different they're they're
all they're all different I mean as far
as the atmosphere on the set the
director's responsible for that
you know for creating an atmosphere uh
that so the atmosphere might be full of
excitement and and uh kind of a feeling
that we're all on edge and anything can
go great or grow go wrong at any time
and that could be a very creative
atmosphere or it can be very
workman-like and that can be a very
creative atmosphere so uh yeah yeah the
director set the tone
ah okay unless they've let that uh Duty
slip away from them
to uh you know
someone else
like a producer or a
or an actor
you know lead actor sometimes will will
take over
if there's a vacuum if there's a vacuum
if the director has not set a tone of
what they want to how they want things
to go on a set then there's a vacuum
someone will probably come in and it
might not go the way you wanted to
and that tone doesn't have to be
verbally set it could be set in you know
action how they how they work with other
people
well it's part of why directing is a
really hard job really complex and hard
job you've got to be very very prepared
you've got to have talked to everybody
ahead of time all the crew chiefs so
that you're well they still call on the
same page and
um so that people so it's actions and
words and and it's uh you know your own
demeanor and and um
uh yeah
it's like any it's like any supervisor
I think you know the manager the the
leadership skills the leadership skills
that you need for any job that's in a
leadership position
what is result Direction result
direction is
telling directing the actor by telling
them how you want what effect you want
them to have on the audience I started
out here's my book oh yes and this is a
read the 25th edition yeah this is the
25th anniversary edition of the my
original book directing actors which
came out in 1996 and I the first chapter
I started out I called it result
Direction and quick fixes
and I started out with a list of at the
time 10 things that that I called result
direction that uh were way ineffective
ways to uh give direction to actors
and I did it on purpose I did it to get
people's attention it backfired a little
bit because people would come to my
workshops afterwards and they'd be
terrified that they're going to say the
wrong thing it's one of the reasons why
I was so thrilled to get the chance to
do this book
and to kind of correct that impression
that when I talk about result Direction
it's it's a quick way to bring up the
subject of subtext
that
that because what I call the quick fixes
which are the verbs the facts or
emotional history uh imagery and
physical life and event
um that that they
they're not always they're not always
that quick they're quick when you know
how to use them
but I but I wanted to have that first
chapter be a way that people would not
lose hope I wanted them to say okay
these are these are the list of don'ts
but there's you know hope there are
things you can do instead and
but but it did it did turn out you know
people would come into my workshops and
I say you know I read that list of
things not to do and I do every one of
them and so I'm terrified of saying the
wrong thing now I never wanted people to
be terrified I never wanted people to
think of result direction as the
language police
I always wanted it to be a way to
introduce the idea
that there's
more to story and more to characters
than just what you see
uh on a on a flat screen that there's
under there's underneath that the people
so the characters people's emotional
history affects what they do now that
the images in their memory and in their
dreams that that affects what they do
now that the that their their intention
their verb or their intention or their
need or their objective that's that's
where their behavior comes uh comes from
and I wanted directors to know more
about that to understand it and not
because they always have to
fix you know tell the actor well don't
play that objective play this one
instead I I I never meant that that's
what I wanted them to do but I wanted
them to understand the tool of objective
of what the character wants or what the
character needs because it's such a
helpful way to talk to actors to ask but
to ask them first what what what is your
objective what do you want here and
so
and also that these tools about subtext
will lead you toward an understanding of
emotional event which is the most
important thing for a director to know
is what is the emotional event of a
scene what is a scene about the simplest
example of result direction is a line
reading
so if a director says to an actor so
let's say the line is uh
don't lie to me the if director says
you're saying the line wrong don't say
don't lie to me say don't lie to me
you know that that's a line reading and
that that's a simple example a simplest
example of of result Direction and I
think by now most directors know they're
not supposed to use that but
um
but but it's still it it often gets hard
for them to understand why and if they
don't understand why it's not a good
idea to give line readings or to just to
tell them I want you to be angrier or I
want you to be uh sadder uh that's
another way to give result directions
say you need to be angrier
and uh
if they don't understand the why of it
it's easy for them to to feel like oh
gosh I'm going to say something wrong
and I'd better not say anything or and
and directors in my workshops they used
to come up to me and say well is it okay
if I say this and I say well you know
it's not the language police you can say
anything you want but
ask them what they understand by it
that's that's a helpful way to do it and
ask them what they're working on and
create a dialogue with them
so
uh but let me give you an example of
of how uh you know result Direction
versus understanding what the emotional
event of a scene is
so
the the scene might be an argument
and and the uh
and it's the director says to the actors
this is an argument between best friends
that could result in the end of the
friendship
that creates the emotional Stakes
and and and it's very specific
direction of where this director wants
the the scene to go
and to say something like that instead
of I want you to be angrier
okay so that's that's that's what I
that's the real reason for studying a
result Direction and The alternatives to
it is so that you can get to an
understanding of the emotional event
which is the which I think the director
is responsible for and should
communicate to the actors
although side note you should always be
ready to change your mind sometimes a
different emotional event works great or
works better and then you can still move
on even if it's not the one you thought
was going to work but that's that's kind
of the the difference between between
result directing
you know I want you to get angrier here
I want you to be more disappointed there
versus talking about the the emotional
events of the story that that this and
to think about the differences in
different kinds of arguments so if you
say this is
instead of saying um this is an argument
between best friends that could result
in the end of the Friendship a different
kind of emotional event a different kind
of argument could be these people argue
all the time they have had the same
argument many times this there there
there's they're arguing this time
there's something new about this
argument I want us to find out what it
is
but I'm thinking it was unlikely to lead
to the end of the friendship
now I also use the terms of saying it's
unlikely to or it could instead of it
will lead to the end of the relation
friendship or won't lead to the end of
the Friendship so that whatever does
happen whatever emotional event does
happen happens in the moment
while the camera is running
so that it's not all
uh
oh you know expect expected it's it's
not all
Pat and sort of paint by the numbers
so if I were in a scene and I'm an actor
and I'm delivering a line very flat and
it's don't lie to me so you're the
director
you're saying
um with result Direction
and and using that it would be to
correct me on my tone maybe but if you
came at it from another angle you'd be
explaining why I'm saying this line
and through that I would know how to put
more emotion to it
well it might be or a real quick verb I
might say what's your intention on this
line
okay so then I'm saying well this is a
friendship
and she doesn't understand me and I've
told her repeatedly don't lie to me
I would say let that come into the line
because that sounds very good to me what
you just said sounds like a very good
way to play it so I'd say let that come
into the line I think that would give it
would give it more spark always see so
the way you said it first right so I'm
developing it so yeah yeah but but uh
let me talk to talk about action verbs a
little bit active verbs uh because if
you
uh
I I did think of an example to do this
um if if the if the line is don't lie to
me
um thought of three different intentions
that we could have it could be I'm going
to pick to convince to accuse and to beg
very different from each other right so
just to give you an example of how that
would be I I'll do a little
a little improvisation of convincing you
of something and the kind of the the
subtext uh underneath convincing is
telling somebody what you think they
should do
so I so I'm going to say
you know I think you should never lie I
don't think you or anybody else should
ever lie don't lie to me
okay so that would be to convince if
it's accused then it's
I know you lied
I know you did you've been lying all
along you've been lying every day of
your life do not lie to me
okay or if it's Bae then it's
I don't know what I'm gonna do if nobody
will tell me the truth I need I need to
be told the truth don't lie to me
okay so it comes out different and there
could be different reasons as you were
asking you know talking about the
reasons why a person might be begging or
a person might be accused and accusing
our person might be convincing but of
course sometimes
sometimes characters do the wrong thing
sometimes they want somebody to be open
and honest with them but they do the
wrong thing to get it if they demand
that they be honest
might not work right
so um
so the verbs can be you know you can
play opposites you can do lots of things
with them but there is always a reason
for them
you say it's a death to the actor's gift
to put their concentration on the effect
they're having on the audience because
they should have their concentration on
their acting partner
okay so if I'm in a scene with you let's
say and it's opening night and I know my
parents are in the audience and high
school friends and I'm just oh I'm gonna
this is gonna be great but really that's
the kiss of death for the actor because
I should be focusing on our scene our
argument our whatever it is that's
binding us up there
well that's the scene the scene is the
relationship
seen as the relationship or
relationships if there's more of the
scene there's more than two people in
the scene
um
yeah that is the scene it's the
relationship and how it changes
the relationship starts out in one place
and it ends up in another place and and
the the process of it change of the
relationship changing that's the
emotional event
that for and and it can be very subtle
it can be very small that in the
beginning they're friends they're good
friends and at the end of the they've
during the uh and during the scene they
exchange intimacies and at the end
they're closer friends than they were at
the beginning
so that that's you know that could be
that could be a scene or that could be
an emotional event
um
but it has to happen in the moment and
the and the safest way for something to
happen in the moment is it is is to be
focused on the response of your partner
now doesn't mean you have to always be
in each other's eye line
you know that one character might be
making a sandwich and the other one is
over there so that you might not you
don't have to always have the the eye
line but but you have to always have the
awareness
of the uh of the other of the other
character the other actor even if it's a
single even if the even if it's a
close-up on uh on this on this factor
that that the other actor even if
they're out of frame they're still in
the scene so they're still
they're still in
the shot even though if they're not
physically in the shot and that is this
the simplest way the strongest way the
most effective way the most reliable way
for an actor not to be not to start
worrying about whether their parents are
going to like it or not is to uh or
whether the director is going to like it
or not or whether uh anything else is is
to is to be is to lose themselves in the
other
in the other actor
um
and you know and and connecting to the
other actor is the thing that that um
awakens an actor to their own impulses
it sounds con uh like a
counter-intuitive but it's true
so let's say we have actor a and actor B
on stage
and actor a is very much about playing
off of actor B and is dialed into them
and has been able to lose the audience
in some sense they don't even realize
they're there but actor B is concerned
with the audience and is concerned with
their performance and there's a
disconnect a can't connect to B Because
B is in its own performance yeah well
the director has to speak to actor B
uh what if
in that moment some people might you
know get it carried away and they run
with it and that actor a can't
have that director intervene it's
supposed to talk about a theater piece
could be a theater piece yeah so how
would it yeah I'm sorry but the director
has much less control than the theater
piece so sure so that's a completely
different thing anyway because they're
you know once they open they start
making their you know they start
changing things so I mean I did it
myself when I was in theater you started
you start throwing out Direction left
and right but but for for film and most
of my people who who uh most of my
readers my book uh directing actors 25th
anniversary edition are film directors
or television and
um so yeah and the directory has a
tremendous amount of control
uh over over things so certainly over
whether to do another take or not
well we still hear about oh sorry we do
still hear about an actor of staging
another actor and kind of running with
it should actor a who's trying to stay
more true to the scene
play off that and some should they bring
that to the performance and B is running
wild and and is unharnessed and is like
wait a minute you're changing all the
rules here should a then say okay I
guess there's new rules here and I have
to go
well that's that's a tough one that did
happen to me when I was doing theater
back in the 70s I was doing this
play it was pretty strange play and uh
and one and it was like five people on
five or six people on stage at once and
sitting together five or six
act female uh characters on stage at
once and we were we were blocked so that
we were sitting in a circle and then
there was one actor there who had the
fewest lines
and and she was playing an old lady and
so she she decided to
pretend that you know she had dentures
and that her Dentures were loose and so
she was doing this kind of thing through
the whole play and my character was my
character was also a little bit of a
crazy person and but I kept my craziness
you know within the bounds of the
direction I'd been given and and the uh
you know and giving making sure that the
actors who are supposed to have Focus
had focus when they were when they were
supposed to have it and but but this one
lady was throwing everything off and uh
a toyed with the idea of picking up on
her energy and being as crazy as her in
order to feel like I was still in the
play but I decided not to so uh but
there were I had some friends who came
who said you know she's actually very
funny she's actually the best thing in
the play and so you should match her
energy and and uh and and go uh and go
ahead so I don't know it it's uh but you
know it's the the director was also in
the play
so she was there every night and
um I wanted to work with her again so I
didn't think she would like it so I
didn't do it but does that answer your
question is that what you meant yeah it
does I'm thinking actually uh was it
Robert Altman's uh come back to the five
and dime Jimmy Dean oh right so you have
Karen Black you have Cher you have all
these different people and they're all
their own star of the show but in
different ways and they don't really
seem to be outshining one another
they're they're contained within their
parts but when their part is up their
brilliant kind of thing
but not everybody works I'm sure who
knows how it was behind the scenes but
for the audience you see this
thing where no one's trying to step over
one another
right well Altman was famous for his
ensembles you know that that and he when
you're asking how does the director set
the tone and and he always made sure
that every everything was at an ensemble
piece so that and and and everybody was
going to get their turn ah everybody was
going to get their turn and and you know
he promoted and created and all for one
and one for all atmosphere on the set by
giving huge amounts huge amounts of
permission I one of my students was in
um
uh the player I think and I had a small
part in in one scene and and she told me
afterwards that he said he wanted them
to do it differently on every take
he said he didn't have to follow
blocking
and they didn't have to say the same
lines
and uh they can do whatever they could
follow any impulse
and I mean it's a brilliant movie right
so so uh that was his way of doing it
and and
um and he knew everything about blocking
he could block really really well you
know the player that opening scene it's
blocked within an inch of its life you
know in order to have that four minute
take everybody has to hit their marks at
exactly the right time so he knew how to
block a scene perfectly but he he could
see if it was there or not and he would
let the act I don't know but that's him
I I never tell my clients or my students
that they should do that you know try to
be Robert Altman he he's he was a genius
and
um but I think he'd let people know
you're gonna get your turn you're you
can uh you can trust me he they I mean
actors trusted Altman
completely
I think that you said the magic word
yeah get your words get your turn yeah
and so you feel like you don't need to
you know mess with the Dentures so to
speak even though you said that your
friend said that it worked but but I
could see that happening where maybe it
could take some people out of the play
and they felt distracted or who knows I
wasn't there but but I like that but you
know if if it's a movie of course you
you could just not use any close-ups of
that of that character it's it's very
easily fixed in the editing room just
don't use the don't use the shots that
she's in if you think she's gone too far
can you explain how a director can
micromanage an actor in their
performance yes by talking too much
that's the quick answer to that there
are uh
directors who uh you know want to they
want to delve into the inner life a lot
they want to talk talk they want to they
want to
um
a front load
that's one that's the thing that I think
is the most dangerous is when you know
the director has a very uh
idea that he or she is very excited
about and they want to front load the
actor with it before before they um
before they even do anything
and they over talk it's the simplest
thing is over talking I finally boiled
it down to telling directors listen more
than you talk and be
percentage about that hear your own
voice less than 50 percent of the time
when you're talking to actors listen to
them more than you talk to them and uh
and and that's a big big thing that that
um that actors complain about is
directors that over talk but they still
don't understand what they what the
directors wants that's that's just so
easy to happen and that's so so very
simply
um
under circumvented if the director knows
understands the tool of emotional event
because that's much takes much less time
to talk about and then if you if you can
say to the actors wait this is this is
not a this is this is not uh a family
you know nice people being nice this is
an argument
and uh and then let the actors get there
however they get there instead of sort
of micro well now you have to you have
to get mad and then you have to be
disappointed and then you have to get
mad back and now you have to and that's
micromanaging is is sort of giving the
result for each each emotional turning
point that you want that's another way
to to micromanage rather than allowing
each actor to have a through line
through an uh objective something they
want or need from the other actor and an
obstacle of course very useful and
um and then let them let let's say ins
and outs of how they win the argument or
lose the argument let that happen in the
moment you know if they both want
something from each other
what if they're not getting the result
they want
I encourage
directors to want a different result
than sometimes they think they do
because sometimes they've gotten married
in their minds to a certain uh that they
think their eyebrows are supposed to
rise at a certain point or there's
supposed to be a certain line reading at
a certain point or there's supposed to
be a certain pitch of anger or at a
certain point and and I try to get them
this is with script analysis I try to
get them to use their script analysis to
get to a different thing to want
to get to the uh the emotional event
that they want uh because if they want
if they want those those uh particular
surface things
I can't tell them how to get it I really
can't so I spend a lot of my time trying
to get them to want something else
so maybe the director doesn't know what
they want
that's how it feels to the actor
that that if the if the director keeps
saying well raise your eyebrow just a
little bit more then the director think
they don't know what they want
they think they want that but they don't
really know what they want and and that
is about the you know what the scene is
about is it is it a
is it about uh survival
is a scene about survival only one will
survive say is the scene about
uh loss of purpose
is the scene about uh it's a scene of
confession that gets accepted
or or not
you know those are the things and it it
it's it's not that easy for for uh
directors to get to that
um it they have to do some script
analysis they have to look underneath
the surface of the script and underneath
the surface of the instructions that the
stage directions give them
uh to to find it and it takes practice
and and it's useful not just for talking
to actors but for talking to anybody for
talking to your cinematographer or
talking to uh you know production
designer or or producers or financial
people it's useful for uh for anything
so it's a different way of looking at
what the scene is supposed to be
what if someone's trying to talk to
someone more because they feel like
they're not getting the truth of what's
going on or there's a disconnect there's
something
that's not being said wait can you say
more about that sure so if if the
director is talking too much uh maybe
they're doing it as a way to fill in the
lines of something that's not being said
or something that's not coming to the
surface so they're using it as a tool
their own tool well actors do the best
they can to
figure out what what the director wants
um so if the director is over talking
now they'll listen for little Clues
to give them something to to try on the
next take
what is the language of permission
it's a way of
um
engaging the
the actors
with the process
it can be as simple as saying
um I had this idea that this could be
that this scene could have higher Stakes
do you want to try that instead of
saying get angrier okay you know uh and
uh so it's that's the language an
example of the language of permission is
uh offering
be offering the actors a way to a way to
you know giving them giving them the
opportunity to say no and then if and
then because it's good to find out if an
actor doesn't like your direction uh
it's good to find out because then you
can say okay well I'm gonna try to make
a case for this let me tell you why I
think this is worth trying and it's it's
very helpful a key element of the
language of permission is that when you
when if if the actor has a different
idea than yours then the director's mine
if I'm the director that I am not if I
discuss it with the actor I'm not trying
to convince them that my idea is better
than theirs but I am trying to convince
them that my idea is worth trying
so it's being soft with people it's not
being abrupt it's asking hey you know
Judith could we try it maybe this way
instead of me dictating to you like
Judith no I need you to do it this way
I'm I'm showing you respect I'm being
soft it's it's partly but I guess if I
use myself as an example when I'm
directing I have a lot of energy so I
don't I wouldn't say that I'm soft I'm
very energetic so it's not an energy
level it's uh
it's it's checking in
it's checking it I wouldn't say it's an
energy level
because I my energy is very high and
when I really want something
I'll say wait okay I maybe I haven't
explained this yet but there's something
that I want that we're not getting to
and let and tell me what you think I'm
saying
you know the to get feedback tell me
what what you and you see how a
conversation like that has to be private
sure but you're checking in instead of
you're checking in giving orders and so
even if the energy is intense there's
still a mutual respect I think so yeah
yeah they're collaborators they're
collaborators they're artists and they
are people
and and uh
and they're smart
so why wouldn't you use all of the
brains on the set
what is an emotional event
an emotional event is something that
happens it's something that happens that
changes the temperature the emotional
temperature of the scene
so it could be a turning point
or it could but it it doesn't have to be
a single moment it can be the what
happens in the whole in the whole scene
so so the whole scene could be an
argument
or well let me mention
Mike Nichols who I quote a lot in my
book directing actors 25th anniversary
edition I quote Mike Nichols a lot in
the chapter on emotional event
because he really really got it he was a
teacher himself and in addition to being
a brilliant director and
[Music]
um
and he said at one time and I'm going to
preface this by saying that I make some
adjustments to this uh victim of Mike
Nichols I I take the Liberty uh he said
every scene is either a fight a
negotiation or a seduction
and
that's a useful way for directors to
kind of get introduced to the idea of
emotional event is it's something that
big and you know they're that different
from each other you know a fight
negotiation seduction they're different
from each other
and uh and that's a helpful way for
people to think about I actually think
that it can be you know refined you know
and our I was using the example before
an argument between best friends
oh who have never argued before is
different from an argument between
people who have had many arguments in in
the past right those are two different
kinds of arguments but um but it it it's
something that it's something that
happens between the the two people the
two characters in the scene that uh that
changes their relationship
so
um
and I in this I'm very proud of this
chapter 5 in
in this book very proud of the chapter
five because I I finally really really
addressed this question of emotional
event I in the first book uh the
original directing actors which came out
in 1996.
I mentioned emotional event and I
mentioned how important it was but I
didn't really describe it and over the
years that I was teaching after that and
people would have they were asked to
read that book before they came to any
of my workshops and the directors would
always say you know I love the book but
I'm still this one thing I'm confused
about and it's emotional event so I so I
kept trying to uh be clearer and clearer
about it and it's a very slippery topic
you know it's one of those things you
know I'd I'd I was in class I would
finally be reduced to saying you know
if you keep watching me men talk watch
scenes and talk about emotional event
you'll eventually be able to do it
yourself and I thought well that's a
cop-out you know I have to be able to uh
to really describe it for them more
clearly and then I TR then I did another
book in 2003 called the film director's
intuition and I I made a stronger
attempt to describe what emotional event
is in that book but I still wasn't
satisfied and people still had the you
know kept asking about it so in this
book the 25th anniversary edition of
directing actors I I really went all out
I spent a lot a lot of time uh trying to
explain it from a lot of different
points of view because it's it's it's
slippery and and uh so I came at it from
different points of view like you could
think of it um does it is the it at the
end of the scene is the relationship
closer than it was at the beginning or
is it more alienated than it was at the
beginning that's a simple way to look at
emotional event and uh some other simple
ways are
uh one character hurts the other
person's feelings
that's an emotional event or one
character uh
asks uh asks for forgiveness and
receives it that's another emotional
event or one person
um uh
try uh tries to pick a fight and the
other person engages you know they pick
a fight with each other
so that's a that the you know so there
are different ways of of looking at it
but
um and it takes a lot of practice to you
know to think about that what is the
event of the scene
and and that it's something underneath
the plot event
and so Mike Mike Nichols said there's
three sort of wants in every scene it's
one to argue no no no that it's either
one of the that has seen as either a
fight or a negotiation or seduction
right so it's it's one of three
yeah I mean it's a it's a I think he was
you know it's it's a very broad thing to
say I mean one thing that uh that it
makes me realize is that
um you can play fast and loose that that
a lot of you would think any love scene
is a seduction right that would seem
automatic but but actually most love
scenes are negotiations
so that's an interesting way to do it
um we'd think that the scenes in Fight
Club where they're having the fights you
would think that those are fights right
but they're really seductions
so you can
I don't know you're looking for what's
underneath it what if a scene does not
have an emotional event you're going to
end up taking it out in the editing room
if it doesn't have an emotional event
it stops this it stops the story so that
even uh scenes that look like a
connector scene or an exposition scene
still need to have an emotional event
there's no such thing as a scene that uh
that that's an exposition scene so I was
very lucky with uh with this 25th
anniversary edition of directing actors
I was I was very lucky to get uh
permission to use a scene from The
Matrix for to do my script analysis uh
example and it's a it's a very short
scene it's like a page and a half and I
think most people would look at it and
think it's a connector scene they're you
know they're they're in a car they've
just derived back to the Matrix and it's
Neo's uh first uh visit back to the
Matrix
I think they're on the way to see the
oracle and um
so it's a connector scene between this
you know very amazing uh
trip from the Nebuchadnezzar
back to the Matrix and then and then
this amazing scene at the at the oracles
uh uh office
and um but but I it's because it's an
excellently written script and I just
found so much in it and so so I was
really I really felt good about being
able to show how something that most
people might think of as a connector
scene had lots and lots of event in it
even if the most simplest Exposition
scene Shakespeare is full of them a
messenger comes up and tell gives
information to the to the king and then
goes off that you could say that the
emotional event is that the messenger uh
you know they achieves achieves their
message that it it raises their stature
in the eyes of the king or it cements
their low stature
when they're when they're dismissed you
you can find emotional event in any uh
so-called Exposition scene and you must
you must
what are the questions that a director
should ask to uncover the emotional
event
great question okay I I go into that a
lot uh and one way that you know and any
question that occurs to you like why are
they here why why is it you can always
start with why is this scene in the in
the script uh why why why do the
characters do what they do why do they
say what they do
um I like to always start with
mysterious lines mysterious lines very
helpful place to start when I'm doing
script analysis so well first I look at
just my my my first impressions
well I I honor my first impressions
where I say uh and even if it's oh this
is a scene that uh looks like a torture
scene you know one person is is beat
beating down the other person
so that would be something I don't like
I don't care for torture scenes so I
would say well I gotta find something
else then and say oh so I so I honor
that I for I have that first impression
or I have the first impression that that
um that's a love scene that these people
are are falling in love
it's one of those little steps along the
way to Falling in Love
so that's so I honor my first
impressions but then I start looking for
mysterious lines and I make myself find
at least three in every scene and and
first I look at mysterious lines the
ones that bother me the ones that it's
my tenants that I my first impression my
first tendency is to say I don't like
this line it shouldn't be here it should
be Rewritten uh I I don't like it and
then make myself come up with three
different ways of understanding it make
myself
and by the time I've done that I
I'm fine with the line I don't I don't I
no longer want it to be taken out which
is very very good thing to use for if
you're directing television if you're
directing television you don't get to
change lines or take them out if you
don't like them not without permission
certainly and and uh you're very
unlikely to get it
so it's very very useful to uh to be
able to find a way to justify any line
that at first you don't like
of course I have a theater background so
that's how I learned that because you
didn't if you're doing a Tennessee
Williams play you didn't say well I
don't like this line can we change it no
you don't you don't get to change it so
so um so you have to find a way to
justify it you know it's finding a way
to justify the line
so I start with the lines I don't like
and then I start with the lines that I
love sometimes there are lines that I
love and then I make myself still look
for subtext to them
instead of saying this line is so good I
just have to say it and it's you know
going to be wonderful I still make
myself look for uh you know what are
three different realities that could be
behind it
now
probably give you an example huh
yeah I would just just real quick what
would make you not like a line
well I was thinking about this this
morning
and I was thinking about because
um
you know like
I I
decided to think of something from
Shakespeare because
you know we don't have to worry about
copyright if I use some lines from
Shakespeare right so I was thinking
about to be or not to be speech which
goes to be or not to be that is the
question
whether it is nobler in the mind to
suffer the slings and arrows of
Outrageous Fortune
or to take arms against a sea of
troubles and by opposing end them
well this is a line that I both love and
hate
the the line about take arms against a
sea of troubles and by opposing end them
I mean I love this line it it seems to
so perfectly
um
say something about the State of Mind of
a of suicide ideation
you know that that the only there's
nothing I have nothing I could do I
can't
and Powerless to change anything any and
um and even
my efforts to change you know I'm
powerless powerless powerless but if I
look at it in a very word by word kind
of way take arms against a sea of
troubles
that's a mixed metaphor
right
why did he do that this is Shakespeare
he doesn't have to mix his metaphors he
he you know he can do anything so why
did he do that you don't like the idea
of shooting bow and arrow into the into
the waves that's the image that comes up
when I think about it you know the Sea
of troubles it's like the waves crashing
over the shore you take a bow and arrow
and and well actually as soon as I say
that I say yes everything that we do in
life is as futile as shooting bows and
arrows into the into the waves
so we'll automatically
I like the line better but then I I say
to myself well make myself come up with
two more
and
um and the another one that of course
comes to me is that you know the mixing
of the metaphors is a product of his
disordered mind
that uh I mean sometimes I think I think
about handled it a lot actually and
sometimes especially in the last week
because I went to see that movie The
Northman which is based on the same uh
Legend the same story as the Shakespeare
used to baste
to base the story of Hamlet and
um
anyway
sometimes I think that Hamlet
Shakespeare's Hamlet
was
uh had early onset schizophrenia you
know brought on by trauma
and uh and that his mind really is and
that this speech which it's so beautiful
that you think it all makes sense but it
really doesn't and it's not meant you
know that it it doesn't make sense
because his mind is going from image to
image
anyway that that's I I just did too I'm
gonna stop because sometimes I talk too
long about Hamlet so
well I'll just I'll just stop there to
come up with at least at least two three
if you can different ways to understand
uh a line that that bothers you
what is subtext the subtext is the thing
that is not being said
so
if
I say
I'm very happy to meet you
um what is it what am I not saying
am I not was the thing I'm not saying is
I've been waiting for this appointment
for six months and I can't understand
why it took so long
and then you know I I'm very happy to
meet you or or or or is it that uh or is
it something else it you know it's the
thing that's not being said and and so
that can come in a lot of forms it can
be
um it can be the uh the history
you know I uh again somebody asked how
are you and I say I'm fine and I don't
give you my whole medical history right
it's uh it's uh it's a long one and uh
so I don't I don't give that to you but
that's always behind every time I say
I'm fine
you know I'm a little bit grateful that
I'm still alive right so that's that's
the subtext for me every time I say I'm
fine but if if you say uh oh here's a
great way to explain subtext
let's say that you have
renovated your house renovated your
living room and put a lot of time and
energy and money into it
and then a friend comes to the door for
the first time and they come in and they
say
oh you changed everything around
right
that was the subtext right it's like
they don't like it that's the subtext
right and but if they come in and they
say you changed everything around then
you know that they did like it so that's
we subtext happens in our daily lives
all the time it's you know it affects
the way that the line comes out it's
it's the emotional Sanford Meisner used
to talk about there's no the the
emotions of the scene or a river the
words are boats that float on that River
so the subtext is the emotional River of
of of the scene or or of the character
and
um
so uh and so sometimes it's a line
reading you know those are two different
line readings for two different subtexts
having to do with this one topic
um it can be you know different a
different history uh it can be a
different uh verb that's what I did with
the verbs with uh don't lie to me could
I read a few couple a few lines these
are mine that I came up with oh great
okay and and so maybe you can critique
me on my delivery of them and also uh
the subtext and it could it could be
okay so the first one is um
I love that dress on you Judith
did Paul tell you he did tell you right
that we used to date
here's another one
dad knows
he wants the money put back in his
account immediately
okay last one
your check is waiting for you in payroll
Security will walk you down and you have
five minutes to clean at your desk
that was awesome
like you're hired okay great I'm gonna
cast you you're fantastic okay thanks
but uh so so different different
meanings for each one so maybe we could
start with I love that dress on you by
the way did Paul tell you
meaning it's someone trying to sort of
undercut someone
compliment I don't know that that's how
I read into it sure sure yeah I think I
I think uh well I think you absolutely
got the idea of subtext that the I love
that dress on you that is not to be
taken literally
sure and it's uh it's uh it has a reason
behind it that's not the literal uh
meaning of the words it's yeah so so
subtext means that the things people say
they're not uh there's something else
behind it there's uh you could call it
an agenda or or uh
you know there's there's something else
now in that case in the case of the
first one the
um that person has is conscious of her
agenda I would say that that and her
intention I would say is to undermine
the person she's talking to sure with
the information that did you know I used
to date Paul that that you're that you
want to undermine uh the person you're
talking to and by beginning with uh uh
the compliment on the dress it's it's a
way to make the the knife in the
knife in the back even even sharper you
know by by uh it's and it's an opposite
okay throws the person off their game a
little bit Yeah so you're saying I love
that dress but the with the attention to
undermine right right it's uh yeah
lovely lovely what about the other did
you want to talk more about the other
two okay so dad knows
he wants the money put back in his
account immediately
so sibling to Sibling Something's
Happened it involves money yeah
um yeah
uh well uh
uh
I guess what what did you feel your
intention was you know I guess you're
right when I when I look at it there's
there's less subtext it seems like it's
pretty obvious but it's not obvious at
all oh no you could do it you could I
could do it completely opposite okay
yeah I'll just try it sure sure
dad knows
when he wants the money put back in the
account
right away
that's that's true that's a softer
that's you know more caressing maybe I
may you know depends on the history
between these two maybe this person has
been having a rough time maybe the
person that your character is talking to
has been having a rough time and uh
and but maybe they both colluded on this
rearranging of funds
and and maybe it's I'm the one that has
to put the the money back
I think the way you wrote it exactly
doesn't make it doesn't make it have to
be the person you're talking to so so uh
you know it's dad knows
and he wants the money put back you know
maybe it's like very practical my dad
knows he wants the money put back
immediately cover blown right that's
true it could be played different ways
so so the so the questions you have or
if you're looking at those lines on a
page are you know what is the history
did the two of these these two siblings
did they collude on these uh on whatever
happened to these uh funds or or uh
or is it the fault of that one or even
just the fault of this one so that's
where those are the kind of questions
that I always start out with with lines
like that are on a page uh you know I I
ask
you know what what's the history
of this uh Caper whatever was done with
the money
right yeah I like that and then lastly
was just and maybe more self-explanatory
just um you know your check is waiting
for you in payroll Security will walk
you down after you've cleaned out your
desk and you have five minutes
yeah well that's a that's an example of
something that could be thought of as
exposition
but uh the way that you you read you
gave it an intention to punish
right which is very reasonable that that
this is the person who's up to here with
with that uh with that person who's
being relieved of their duties and um
and
the subtext that I heard when you read
that was that
person is off my back out of my you know
this person it's this nightmare is is
gone but but again if you saw it on the
page there's other possibilities that it
could be it it it it could be that this
that the person speaking fought to keep
this uh
fought to keep this uh this person at
their job
and uh and if they could even be crying
or they were the reason the person's
fired so yeah there could be different
it could be yeah you know yeah I I
thought your choices were just marvelous
but but that's very uh helpful uh
example about you know if we saw it each
of those lines on a page we could really
ask all these questions to get at what
what their subtext is
and would it depend on the tone in which
they're said well tone is another word
for verb I think you know like a teasing
tone is the verb to tease
so uh yeah tone is another way of
talking about it
great I like the verbs because they're
so
because they're so uh muscular
if a scene does not have subtext what
can a director do to add it in
you have to believe that it does have
subtext and look for it
that's I I just feel that so strongly
that uh there's no sometimes when I was
teaching workshops on uh with actors and
directors working together and bringing
in scenes that they'd worked on and
sometimes people will say well this is a
very straightforward scene
um
I would just say I want you to take that
out of your vocabulary this is a
straightforward scene there's no such
thing
and it if if it really is then probably
should be Rewritten so that there's
something extra in it you know so that
there's some twist something that that
lets us into the personalities and
predicaments of these of these
characters and or foreshadows something
in this story that uh yeah a
straightforward scene
probably doesn't belong in the movie
so so uh so and sometimes they need to
be Rewritten but uh but sometimes the
the filmmaker hasn't looked hard enough
for uh for something else that could be
there
that's what I think so with
straightforward almost code for there's
no life to it that's it's too dry well
it's code for exposition oh okay
or or a connector a connector scene this
is a connector scene this uh
yeah right okay so when you talked about
Neo in the one scene in your book
um you said it was sort of a connector
scene but it seemed like that wasn't
that straightforward I mean there was
you know he's having a memory of a
restaurant I believe oh yeah it's partly
you know how great the writing is but uh
because so much is evoked and such
there's so much imagery in it
so much imagery the image of the of the
the noodle place
of the yeah the image of the noodle
place it it's so important you know it
gives us so because we see very little
of um
of uh
of Neo when he's Thomas Anderson
you know at the beginning of the of the
movie and and this gives us a whole
picture of Thomas Sanderson
sitting alone
in a noodle place on his lunch hour
or with somebody you know and uh and it
it's it evokes it it it takes us
somewhere
I mean he goes somewhere we go with him
what's the purpose of script analysis
purpose of script analysis is to figure
out what there is to be shot
and that's you know the core of the
scene the the
some people call it the Nugget of the
scene the uh the what it's about the I
like to use this term emotional event
and I tried to find something catchier
but it just expresses what I want to say
so I stick to it but um
it's to it's to find out what there is
to be shot I was talking to a former
student of mine just a few days ago
who's been directing television well
first she she did a she did a beautiful
beautiful independent feature film that
uh oh just wonderful a couple of years
ago and then from that she started
getting some work doing television
and so we were we were having lunch with
with her and another former student and
and she was saying that she felt still
felt really puzzled about how to figure
out how to do television because
you know it it's because there's no time
she had spent a whole year preparing for
her for her uh feature film that her
independent feature film and uh and and
she she was just puzzled like like
because I she said I don't know how to
be sure that I get what I have to get
and I said well you know I think you're
looking at it from the wrong point of
view you you have to you have to do the
work to figure out what it is you want
to get you have to you have to start not
just with don't start with what what
angles camera angles you want start with
what the scene is about
and
um
yeah start there and then and I talk in
in this new book my dollhouse approach
to
figuring out your blocking to uh to get
some Dollhouse dolls or action figures
or Lego figures and
uh and put some furniture around on a
tabletop and and move them around and
see where they see where they want to
move
when you while you're seeing the lines
or where they want to stay stay in one
place and then figure out your your shot
list from from taking uh from from
looking at that through a viewfinder
and
um
but but that those places where but to
have an idea before you start moving
them around of what the scene is about
what what happens to these relationships
how do people hurt each other how do
they help you rescue each other how do
they how does a love how does how do
they take one more step in a love story
or one more step in a breakup and
and that that's where you always have to
start
and uh and and it will get easier to
figure out your shot list if you start
there if you start with I have to come
up with a shot list well like should I
do this shot should I you won't have a
reason for choosing any particular shot
so you need to know what this what the
scene is about in order to have a reason
for choosing the shots
so even even setting up a mock set with
a Lego figures or whatever even if it's
two stationary figures having a
discussion whether it's positive or
negative just I well see this is me and
that's why this is a suggestion I'm not
saying everybody should do this or has
to do this but for me I uh
it does help if I take my two Lego
figures and I just sit them down here
and I say the lines out loud while
they're right here and I and I feel it
in my fingers no this person doesn't
want to move over here this person
doesn't want to move over here they're
they're I don't know it it it you have
to try it to see if it works for you I
mean I'm not saying it would work for
everybody but but but it uh
it's you know how some people say that
they prefer when they're writing they
prefer to write long hand because it's
more physical than their their fingers
are more connected to their brain that
way
it's actually the opposite for me I find
my fingers more connected to my brain if
I'm using a keyboard but uh but anyway
but whatever connects your body to
itself to your your body to your brain
is always going to be is always going to
be a good thing uh
so so so I think that that that that
that that that helps clues in a
screenplay sort of underlying world of
behavior
can you talk the clues well that's a
script analysis you're looking for Clues
if you know if a character says uh uh I
remember you were the you know you were
the worst uh
you were the worst drunk in the dorm
well that's a clue they went to college
together
right that's a very simple clue and
um uh yeah you're looking for Clues like
that so that everything doesn't have to
be spelled out what are the best ways
for directors and actors to unpack a
screenplay
they're gonna they do that work
separately
usually
usually they would do that works
separately now there are exceptions of
course I have seen tape heard about and
seen tape of a rehearsal for the Social
Network directed by David Fincher where
they all sat in a room all the actors
and they uh and the director and the
writer I think was also in the room
Aaron sirkin and and they went through
the whole script line by line and talked
about what each line meant
so that would be if that can be done and
that would be unusual
but
movie came out very good so uh that's
very interesting to note that and and um
and and I think directors and actors can
do this this can even be done on Zoom
one one at a time that uh you know a
director and a lead actor can go over
all the line all the lines of their
scenes all of their scenes and allow
themselves the idea of talking about
what each line means is that you're
allowing questions you're you're even
starting with the question what does
this line mean with the understanding
that it might not mean what it literally
says it means and and just asking that
question what does this line mean
is you're on the way to acknowledging
that it has subtext
and I'm wondering who determines what
the line means is that the writer
director because the actor could embody
this character and it turns out they
actually may know some of the motivation
in some ways better
you're so right so it's very that's why
it's good to ask questions though you
know I one thing that I say to directors
is you will be they're afraid of being
judged by actors sometimes and I said
you will be judged by the quality of
your questions more than by uh the the
uh exactitude of your answers
so a good question is better than a
answer
but you got to have good questions so
that's the so that's the reason for
doing script analysis is so you'll have
good questions
and and then you know but if you're
using questions with actors which I
recommend that you uh Direct by acting
by asking questions you have to be
prepared for the director for the actor
to answer with something that you're not
expecting
so this is similar to a table read
uh
I like to call it a company read rather
than a table weeks I like to do them
without tables but but yeah my table
read is the usual uh description well
this table read that they did with you
know the whole company and or maybe just
the main characters the main characters
and for the Social Network that that was
around a table and
um but but what I liked about it was
just this idea that for every line you
could say let's talk about it and it's
it assumes there could be some something
more to it than just the literal uh
words so say the literal words are I'm
uh I'm tired of talking about this
okay so that could be the literal line
I'm tired of talking about this then
if you say well what does this line mean
then you're you're opening the idea that
it it could mean
I actually think you're tired of talking
about this and I'm going to let you off
the hook I mean the obvious thing is I'm
tired of talking about this just shut up
right that's the obvious meaning but it
might mean something else even opposite
like I I see your eyes uh wandering and
maybe we should go on to something else
so so or it could be uh or it could be
I'm afraid this is going to get into
Dangerous Waters and uh
and there are things about me that I
don't want you to know
so let's stop talking
so it could mean it's opening the door
to to choices
to choices and as far as making the
choices here's here's something so
important
is that there are certain choices that
the actor and director must agree on
you know in order to be on the same page
about the story they're telling but
there are so many choices that they
don't have to be on the same page about
that that where the choices can be left
up to the actor
that the actor can have secrets
the actors can have secrets they can
have secrets from their other actors
and they can have secrets even from the
director
yeah this is uh this is really important
and now the director is responsible for
saying the scene Works let's move on to
the next one or saying no I'm still not
satisfied I want to work on it some more
oh but
they're they don't have to say make this
choice
because and and the and the thing is
that they don't know
when you have an idea it's an idea if a
director has an idea for a choice that
they think that the objective to
humiliate the other person is going to
work for the scene that's an idea it it
doesn't it's it's not the scene until
the actor tries it and it works
so yeah
and when a director gives an actor a
secret
that none of the other cast will know
when is that happening is it a little
note are they pulling him aside having a
little chat seems any anytime anytime it
can happen anytime yeah yeah the
director can suggest a secret
but but again I would always do that
with the language of permission to say I
was I was wondering if maybe they uh
did talk about this one time before and
it's just that the other your character
you're talking to doesn't remember
that could be a secret
it can be it's a very simple one or it
could be very big uh Secret
but uh yeah it could happen anytime
and that's a that's about a big part of
a director's Talent is is being able to
have a you know their intuition their
leadership skills is being able to have
a sense of you know when when to step
when to step in when to step back
knowing when to step in when to step
back now that's something that I uh
I can't tell people you know they have
to get it by experience
they have to practice and practice and
do and try things over and over and and
uh
and then then develop an intuition about
when to step in when to step back when
to leave an actor alone and let them
figure it out themselves
went to
when to step in and say are you
struggling can I help
I had an idea it might be worth trying
why are verbs so important to directing
and acting
because they express Behavior
and that's what we're looking for we're
looking for the behavior of the
characters to tell the story the
behavior of the of the characters in
interaction with each other their
relationships and their behavior and
reaction to good news or bad news
and um and the events of the of the plot
um
so
and and verbs are very important because
they put the actors
focus on the other actor
so if I'm
deciding that my character should be
angry or have been told that my
character is angry then my focus is on
myself am I angry enough
whereas if my I'm is using the verb to
punish
then I'm punishing the other person my
focus is on you are you punished yet
I don't know I don't think you're
punished enough
so I'm gonna I'm gonna keep doing it
okay and that that keeps me going and it
keeps it keeps the it keeps the anger
crescendoing actually and I have and not
just crescendoing but having Hills and
Valleys and you know ex you know
expressive expressive uh nuance
okay so because I'm focused on you on
your reaction rather than on me am I
angry enough that's what that that's the
center of why verbs are so helpful
and so what I call the verb family I put
a bunch of things in there the uh the
the active verbs which you could make a
list of demand beg punish seduce flirt
and courage right
um and which are also called intentions
a lot of these things are used the terms
are used differently by different people
and then there's the objective which is
what the character wants in the scene
and so strictly speaking the objective
is what the character wants the verb is
what or intention is what they're doing
to get it so if I want you to
um to uh calm down
okay then uh I might hint that I want
you to calm down
maybe you could lower your voice a
little bit
I'm not saying this to you obviously you
have such a lovely sweet voice but uh uh
or but if and but what if I use the
wrong verb you know what if I demand
that you calm down calm down
well it's it's a very unfortunate verb
to use if you want somebody to calm down
because it's you know it's like with
it's like with dogs right if dogs are
barking and you tell them to stop
barking you're just doing what they want
you to do they just think oh they like
me barking they're barking back so um
anyway people are like that too and and
so
so demanding that somebody calmed down
is is is is foolish it doesn't work and
yet people do it all the time
you see it all the time
certainly with their dogs but but but
also with with each other demanding that
somebody uh calm down so people make
mistakes people act irrationally
so verbs are very helpful for finding
irrational Behavior like it would be
irrational to demand that somebody
calmed down but but characters and
people do it all the time
so it's an opposite right it's opposite
to the thing that would that will work
so uh verbs are great for uh
okay but also so the objective and the
need and also the spine there's a spine
a character may have a spine for the
whole for the whole um
or the whole script
um and it may not it may not be the same
as the as the script as the plot spine
can you explain what that is
the spine the spine it's it's uh it's
who the person is in a kind of very
basic level I I like to say that I think
that this that the a person's spine a
character's spine is in place by the
time they're eight years old
so by the time
well uh
I had a disabled mother
which happened when I was four
so a spine of putting the needs of other
people ahead of my own
was
just happened I didn't choose it but it
happened
right so those things and they follow
you throughout your life and you can
still be a very assertive person which I
am in some ways but that there's it's
something that it's it's it's in your
emotional DNA it's it's it's it's a it's
a part of you
if that makes sense and and and finding
those things it it's helpful for finding
who who the character is who who are
they really so verbs of course work
great for comedy because opposites
because uh because opposites work great
for comedy so if if somebody is
complaining about how they just they uh
somebody that their co-workers uh threw
them a birthday party yeah like they
threw me a birthday party you know that
could be funny
right because it's inappropriate it's an
inappropriate it's incongruous and
inappropriate uh verb for the subject
matter of the
of that they're talking about
if we can just go back to spying for a
woman I'm sorry to jump around but no
that's fine I really like that so if we
take Forrest Gump there's two there's
actually several great spines because
there's there's Forest there's Jenny
there's Captain Dan or Lieutenant Dan
sorry there's so there's there's uh
Bubba there's so many spines but if we
just took the two main ones so we see
that Forest
um you know he he sort of has his own
spine of seeming like the one that was
sort of weak but he was actually
stronger than everybody else in many
many ways and and and always kind of
coming out ahead and then we had the
spine of Jenny who unfortunately uh
seemed to repeat itself a lot in her
life
and and and the mother you know played
by Sally Field she had a spine of always
kind of making sure that forest was
treated fairly and that he had it good
so I think I'm now I'm understanding the
spine because at first I didn't know
well I think I would say that forest
forest Gump's spine is to take care of
people
that's what I that's what strikes me is
he takes
uh he takes care of other people
that that's what he always does it's his
another way to think of it is it's his
habitual uh behavior is to take care of
people
I don't know that that's what just
struck me
and and Jenny of course has a strong
self-destructive streak
and you know and sometimes people have a
spine of punishing themselves
laughs
for whatever reason there's always a
reason
although you know of course it could be
genetic sometimes people are born with
certain proclivities and that becomes
the way that their their lives go
now I'm going to start looking for the
spine I like that and it's a great
analogy too because I think of the spine
of a book almost and just yeah guiding
the people the important thing to
remember is it's not something that the
person chooses
it's but it describes them
and it can be helpful even if it's a
character and and people don't know what
their spine is I mean when I said that
about me I don't know if that's true I
think it is but uh but most of the time
people don't know their own spine they
don't think about it and
um and characters don't know they're on
spine but it still can be helpful if the
actor does
and it still can be a tool that a that a
director and and and I think if a
director was talking about spine with an
actor to to have it be kind of casual
you know rather than saying okay let's
sit down and decide what your spine is
I I I don't think that's you know
because it starts to feel like you're
filling in blanks but
but if it comes up about the scene well
you know if you're saying well
you know
there's almost this
sense that that the Forest spine is to
take care of other people
it's an opposite because he actually
needed to be taken care of himself
and of course that brings up the mother
you know it's uh maybe she did such a
good job of taking care of him that he
can he has this serp he has this uh this
uh model of taking care and he has
Surplus
resources to take care of others
and I don't know you start to feel like
okay now that's a family and I can
understand it a little bit
so just like in life how other people
show us our spine in a movie other
characters will show the protagonist yes
the relationships the relationships are
where they come out
Judith is it true that relationships
tell the story not plot I know I've said
that
and I know I meant it
but don't get me wrong I love a good
plot
I love love love a good plot with lots
of surprises and a real you know tightly
uh tightly created plot
but once you have a great script of
well-written script and a well-written
script has to have a a tight plot and
and
wonderful plot and it also has to have
theme it has to have an idea of of what
it's about and what what its purpose is
in the world
so it it has to have a good plot and a
good uh and a
um a theme that matters
but the thing that brings those to life
brings the theme the idea slash theme to
life and the plot to life are the
relationships the the scenes because the
scene by scene that uh that things
happen to the characters well let's say
The Godfather godfather has a great plot
right terrific plot and
um
and it's also got a very big theme
family it's about family
and and it's also got lots of sub themes
it's you know got lots of thematic
material there about I mean you know the
the great uh immigration uh from Europe
to the United States in the 20th century
there there's there's lots of uh
capitalism the perversion of capitalism
and by the mafia and
and in capitalism in itself even so uh
so it's got a lot of themes and couple
always said that the central theme was
family
um so it's got a great theme everybody
cares about family uh and it's got a
great plot full of surprises and but
always inevitable every every plot thing
comes out of uh the thing that's
happened before
but what activates what activates the
great plot and the great ideas of of the
movie are the relationships of of uh
Michael's relationship with his father
of Sonny's relationship with his father
uh Fredo's relationship with his father
and then and then Sonny's relationship
with uh with um Michael and uh
everybody's relationship to Connie the
baby of the family and uh so
that's that's what that's what makes the
ideas
and the plot come to life is the
relationships that that's all I meant by
that so if we looked at the Godfather
how much did those relationships with
let's say the the Father and Son
relationships
really matter to the story or were they
everything in the story they're
everything
they're they're everything as far as
making the story work
you know I don't know if you're watching
there's this uh thing on uh television
of this uh miniseries uh called the
offer and it's about the making of The
Godfather
and of course I
watching it and and they recreated just
in the last episode they recreated
something that Coppola decided to do
like a couple days before they started
shooting he invited all of the cast all
of the principal cast to all of all of
the cast that's of Corley owned family
member invited them to a restaurant and
they all had dinner together and he said
you know he didn't tell them to do
anything in particular but I'd always
heard this story and then then I then we
saw it in the in this episode where they
started uh interacting with each other
in character and improvising improvising
a Corleone family dinner and um so maybe
you're talking about improvisation
because I'm a great believer in
improvisation I love improvisation so I
think that uh
allowing space and rehearsal for the
actors to improvise with each other
improvise the relationships if if you
use rehearsal for just saying the lines
of the scenes over and over and over
this rehearsal is going to get make
things worse instead of better so
improvisation has to be a part of of
rehearsal I think in order for it to be
at all useful where you're you're
improvising the subtext you're
improvising the relationships rather
than just saying the lines over and over
so
yeah I I don't know if I correctly
interpreting your your question but but
that uh
that's what
uh
yeah that's how that's how improvisation
is a useful rehearsal tool
and this capitalist story is a really
good example of it